خروج الايرانيات الى الشارع بدون حجاب لم
يكن ممكنا من قبل او حتى تصوره حدوثه وبدا
اشهر من الاحتجاجات قررت بعض النساء عدم
ارتدائه لكسر القيود المتعلقه به
يجب رفع القيود على الحجاب هذا الاجراء
ليس جيدا ولا ينبغي ان يكون الزميا احب ان
ارى الشعر ويجب ان يستمر الوضع على هذا
النحو على النساء ارتداء ما يحلو لهن
والخروج بحجاب او بدونه
من قبل شرطه الاخلاق وضعها الحجاب بشكل
غير لائق كما تقول السلطات الايرانيه هزت
البلاد موجه احتجاجات غير مسبوقه وحدت كل
الاختلافات العرقيه والدينيه في البلاد
لم اخلع حجاب خلال الاحتجاجات الاخيره ولا
مشكله لدي في ارتائه لكني لا اتفق مع كونه
الزاميا فكل واحد حر في اختياراته وللمراه
حق قبول الحجابي او رفضه
القيود المشدده التي تفرضها الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه على النساء
وتصريح السلطات الايرانيه عن الغاء جهاز
الشرطه الاخلاق
وبعد ثلاثه ايام من اضراب التجار والعمال
وصلت الحركه ايضا الى قرنائيه مثل قريه
هيزران الغرب ايران حيث قررت تجار ايضا
للانضمام الاضراب
وخلال زياره الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
اليوم الى جامعه طهران اكد ان على الحكومه
الى مطالب الطلاب مؤكدا على ان الاحتجاج
ماله الاصلاح والكمال لكن اعمال الشغب
التي تشهدها ايران اليوم تسهم في الدمار
وبث روح الياس في المجتمع يضيف الرئيس
الايراني